hey guys Peter Brown and Justin here and
I think you know we're coming to the end
I see yes and this year has proven that
the gaming landscape is changing more
than ever in years past maybe it was a
graphics card that you would see are
some weird proprietary third-party
controller but there are so many
different innovations popping up at this
show in particular that are worth
pointing out and one of the big ones
that I think might really have a big
impact on the road is cloud gaming we've
got in video with their grid system
which is a you know off-site server
based cloud streaming service and then
you've got PlayStation now which i think
is really going to talk to the console
audience the big question is how well
are these going to work because if it's
these aren't final services the nvidia
grid is something that is going to be
going into beta that some people are
using now PlayStation now is going into
bait at the end of the month if these
things don't do well if these things
aren't the high performance thing that
people expect if if the performance
isn't is good if the latency is too high
like these are things that are just
gonna fall they're gonna fail on the x
but if they're doing really well this
could be something that potentially
changes the entire console landscape
another big topic has popped up not just
in gaming but also in his entertainment
in general are 4k displays gaming itself
is sort of growing with this technology
and we're seeing games like Assassin's
Creed 4 already shipping with 4k support
with all their high res textures the
technology is still young but I think
CES is showing us that it's really only
going to be a matter of a couple years
before people will have these ultra HD
displays in their living room playing
these amazing looking games one of the
other really big innovations we're
seeing at CES is the changing in mobile
and tablet gaming and how it's becoming
more and more popular and one thing is
the Tegra k1 chip which I think could be
a really big game-changer yeah and video
has been started innovating a lot in the
mobile space over the past few years
with their Tegra line which is now the
Tegra 4 but what the k1 is doing that's
really special is it is bringing a
desktop grade kepler cuda cores to
mobile devices and what that means is
that we're seeing graphics that are on
par with playstation 3 and xbox 360
which is something that traditionally
mobile couldn't really handle i think
there's still a challenge of dealing
with you know how you control these
games right it's a that's sort of a
thing that needs to be explored a little
bit more but if anything the technology
is really starting to catch up as things
shrink and become a lot more powerful
and Tegra k1 is the first example of I
think what we'll be seeing a trend
leading
down the road oculus VR has become sort
of a familiar face over the past year or
so at different events and their their
VR rift headset is continuing to improve
with every show and right now they've
added positional tracking and better
displays they're getting closer and
closer to the consumer model but I think
once we finally get there as impressive
as it is now it's going to be phenomenal
and I think change gaming for a lot of
people they don't like to give us hard
details on the other things that are
working on but they do definitely like
to tease us this was my first time
getting to try it out and just having it
move so naturally with you putting you
inside so basically inside the game is
such a cool experience if they add the
ability to track your hands and maybe
partnering with some other guys to make
some gay I know John Carmack is working
with them now directly to make games for
the system this could be something that
is really really big data line and last
but not least it's sort of an inevitable
thing that we're going to talk about it
is steam machines we've been talking
about it a lot this week there are so
many things to say so many questions
that are left unanswered but one thing
that's for sure is that Valve's
initiative is mixing up the gaming space
it started putting a lot of pressure on
PC manufacturers and console
manufacturers and I think we're going to
see that a year from now a couple years
from now steam machines are going to be
a very viable product that is really
going to change the marketplace yeah a
lot of people maybe are trying to couch
this as a console killer which i think
is overstating what they're going to be
able to do in a short amount of time but
it's the way that they're going to
change the marketplace as a whole and
especially if they're successful in the
ways that we're hoping they are along
with cloud gaming steam machines could
could be something that really changes
what we think of as gaming and how we're
able to access games yeah and you know
with that that's basically the most of
what we've seen is CES and it's all been
pretty impressive figure sionally the
show is not pretty much about gaming but
the thing is as gaming grows and the
technology grows it's going to sort of
start to penetrate the mass market and
it's really interesting to see what's
happening and I'm looking forward to see
us next year to see where the
technologies that are exciting today
will be when they have a little more
time to mature alright guys thanks again
for sticking with us all week we have a
few more things coming but this has been
a great CES and there's a lot more to
come stay tuned and gamespot follow us
on social media you know how to do it
thanks for watching
you